[Music]
let's go to mariana in
los angeles california what's up how are
we doing
good in yourself dr john man we are
rocking on
is it super super super early
yeah well yeah i came early to work to
make it on time but yes it's super early
hey what is that like getting to work
early on time does that feel good i have
a fantasy that it feels so good
it does feel good um but the other day i
set off the alarm in the building and i
didn't know what to do because i just
got a promotion here so that was pretty
scary
you get a promotion and you're already
breaking and entering good for you way
to go marianna that's awesome so hey
what's up congratulations on your
promotion by the way that's pretty rad
thank you thank you so much
uh well my question today is in regards
to a disagreement i have with my husband
i love getting in the middle of these
excellent
it's in regards to child care um
more so with his ex so so we have four
boys our three older ones are from his
previous marriage
and
we have them friday through sunday and
their mom has them monday through
thursday okay and there's been quite a
few times now
more so
in the beginning it seemed like
emergencies where she uh either couldn't
miss work or um or someone got sick one
of the boys things like that
um so
the only person that could be there is
my mom because my mom takes care of our
little son so so she would go and either
pick up the the kids from school or take
care of them if they didn't have school
whatever the case may be
and now it's more so that she's because
she has been relying
fully on my mom and and my mom kind of
just thought it was it was temporary and
she recently last week told us that she
doesn't want to um you know i guess
quote-unquote help her if anything she
doesn't want to take care of the boys
when it's on her time she needs to
either figure it out because she has a
lot of family so my mom has this
perspective that you know she she has
other ways and asking for us for help
um
and and it's true because the only
person that we would trust to take care
of the boys in any circumstance would be
my mom which is not all the time because
we're usually we are there i should say
we are there for them uh when when it's
our time sure so hold on i'm kind of
getting lost here so
you and your husband you'll have a
little one right now together yeah and
he has
some other kids some other boys from a
previous
relationship
and
his ex from the previous relationship
y'all share custody so i'm gonna take
you out of this so him and his ex share
custody
and he gets them some of the time and
she gets them some of the time
and
once or twice your mom
bailed them out
your mom helped out with child care
helped your husband's ex
out with child care
right
and then all of a sudden your husband's
ex liked that it was free and always
accessible and now it's turned into an
all the time thing and your mom is
saying i didn't sign up to take care of
your husband's ex's kids i'm out
right and and she loves she loves the
boys she's probably the best grandma
that they have and and i love that but
in and it's not more so it's not her job
doesn't what it's not
yeah
and and my husband now you know has a a
connotation of her that she
said it's not about
his ex it's about the boys we have to
take care of the boys all the time and i
totally get that honestly life would be
a lot better if i burst my kids you know
myself like it's hard to it's hard to
try to make her responsible if that
makes sense or how do we do that how do
i get myself here here's here's the
thing
your mom
is a grown woman
who can do whatever she wants to do
right
and if she wants to
help with child care great
if she doesn't
great she's allowed to do that
and you and your family looking at her
and saying y'all are abandoning us you
don't love us you have a responsibility
to do these things
is inaccurate not true that's not fair
to you
to your mom
right i'm proud of your mom for
putting the boundary up and saying hey
i'm running out of weeks and months of
my own life
and i want to do some things that don't
include bailing out your husband's
ex-wife or ex-girlfriend or whatever she
is
yes and so that stinks for you all
because you all have to come up with
some more money
or more importantly these boys birth mom
is gonna have to
get her stuff together
okay and if she puts them in situations
where they're not safe that's what you
and your husband but your husband's
going to go first
are going to go back to court and seek
full custody because she's putting him
in situations that aren't safe but
that's between y'all
not your mom
right
and that's what i try to explain to him
because because he tells me would you
rather have them stay with strangers and
that's not i would never do that right
but
you're you're
that's that's gaslighting at its finest
that is blaming somebody else for their
boundary
that's not the only option the other
option is you all hire somebody that you
trust
and y'all don't go out to eat as much or
y'all
have to live in a different house that
is less expensive or drive different
cars i mean there's some major
sacrifices to having as many kids that's
not your grandma's responsibility i mean
it's not your mom's responsibility it's
not their grandma
a once a month
or an arrangement where y'all pay her
something like that
i'm all in on that but it's if she draws
a boundary she drew a boundary
right
when somebody draws a boundary we can
run up against it and it's normal i do
the same thing
run up against it and
crash into the boundary and see if it's
real
and
when you find out it's real then you
have two options you can respect the
person and their boundary or you can go
to war with the boundary it doesn't
change the boundary it just changes how
much your life is good or how much your
life sucks
and so
i would honor the fact that your mom has
boundaries and then just be about
deciding what's next it's not either or
there's 50 different options here
something about this makes me think your
mom feels taken advantage of and i think
she might be right yeah
yeah and i feel the same way and i i
agree with her but i also don't want my
husband to gain resentment towards her
because of it because he's not he's not
understanding what i what i think and i
understand where he comes from i mean he
grew up in foster care he wants to be
the best daddy absolutely absolutely he
is but
i i can't help him
get over that guilt that's not for him
if that makes sense that's right so can
i tell you a really hard thing that's so
so challenging and difficult and
heartbreaking
you can't control him
you can't control his thoughts you can't
control his actions you can just love
him
and you can have your own boundaries
and one of my boundaries would be
hey we're not going to talk bad about my
mom anymore she's made her choice and
now we're going to make other decisions
either one of us is going to quit
working for a season and stay at home
and we're going to deal with the loss of
income or we're going to hire somebody
but this is the reality that we're faced
with and it's not her responsibility to
make our fantasy about a perfect little
family
come true
or we may circle back to mom and say hey
mom can we hire you
and x is gonna
spend the money because it's her
responsibility cause it's her time that
she's keeping these kids right
um right
and if she can't do that then she can't
do that
and unfortunately you're
there's not i don't see an unfortunate
here other than the pictures is
everybody wants it to be a certain way
that it's just not
and the quicker you all make peace with
that and then come up with the next plan
oh my gosh man so much more peace
involved there and you just can't hate
on your mom for saying hey whoa whoa i'm
getting taken advantage of here
yeah no and if x doesn't want these boys
then x and your husband need to have a
hard conversation about that
right if she wants the idea of wanting
these boys but doesn't want to be around
for him doesn't have time to be around
for him doesn't have the money to pay
for child care that's a court situation
that's a full custody situation that's a
whole different picture
right right
yes
i know this is so hard mariana i know
it's hard about it's hard on your mom
it's hard on you because you want this
thing to be beautiful and perfect
and your husband's heartbroken right
yeah yeah yeah he is
i'm so sorry
it's a messy messy situation
but on honor your mom's boundaries here
i'm going to sit down with your husband
and say
my mom has made a boundary
and so we're going to be done hating on
mom
she's bailed out your ex for
x number of years she's done with that
she's let us know respectfully cool now
we have to make other decisions let's
make other decisions and let's focus our
energy there and every time the
conversation goes back to well if she
would just the conversation's over that
part of our life is done
let's decide we're going to do next
carrying that brick around is a waste of
time and then when you see her on
thanksgiving hug her
she's been bailing you all out for years
hug her she made her call
i know it's so hard man i know it's so
hard and this has a lot of baggage for
your husband too he's carrying a lot of
the stuff he's carrying it with him
because he remembers his childhood and
he wants it to be different from his
boys
it can be different and it will be
different and he is a great dad and
you're a great stepmom
here but it's gonna look different than
the fantasy that he's got in his head
and that's okay he's gonna work hard to
make it happen